actually let me tell you storm in do you
know that did you know that lethal crime
is way way down around the world
no I didn't know yeah so I crimes that
result in death have dropped
dramatically since when in the past I
think like twelve or thirteen years
they've been they've been on the decline
cool and you know why what's great news
what would you think the reason is why
that would be I would like to I mean I
guess it was just because I want to say
times are good and like people are
prospering that's that's what you'd
think when you see the data where it's
like the homicide rate is going down the
reality is the invention of cell phones
oh the same crimes are being committed
but now when someone gets stabbed
someone calls 911 right away and
treatment arrives in the minutes whereas
before cell phones they'd run to find a
phone and the person will bleed out on
the sidewalk so the people are getting
charged with attempted murder or
aggravated assault or solve the deadly
weapon not murder I see yeah so now that
rates for murder is going way down it
makes sense not that humans are
committing less crimes it's that our
technology improves oh it's still there
we're just still there being able to
save people but crime is going down
typically too so yeah ok so I bring that
up because everyone's going right now
like young people aren't even doing like
slow do we care than these kids go out
and start doing shots of each others
butts like that's what literally the
video is I'm not kidding it's like we're
looking they're doing a human but it's
real its seat on an airplane like what
corona virus challenge there's like a
human eye why are you doing this why
please continue for internet points
knows like a video they're doing like a
human centipede beer pour where they all
like put their heads under each others
butts and pour beer and drink it oh my
god hey man you got a party hard right
that is bad so here's the thing though
oh because young people are responding
well to the technology the mortality
rate for young people is low and they're
like so it's not even killing young
people it's like dude do you want to end
up in the hospital with a ventilator
shoved down your throat pump oxygen your
lungs but you're they're failing
whatever man reminds me minds me of that
kid who put the tide pod in his mouth
yeah because they weren't really eating
them yeah but then his saliva broke it
and then he and then as soon as it broke
it burned him and he aspirated and then
it went in his lungs and they started
coughing and gagging and whose dude that
must man brutal scar scar tissue all
as long as that dudes gonna get an
oxygen tank for the rest of his life
kids are dumb dude I feel bad because
they're just ignorant and arrogant want
attention yeah everybody wants attention
that's all it is man mm-hmm
so basically now we're looking at
national lockdown I guess I don't know
what's gonna happen yeah we actually
have another story Alan to pull up on
these kids doing all this stuff but I
don't know man
there was a there was that viral text
messages text message did you get one of
those I don't think we're there like I
heard this from my brothers uncles aunts
cousins wife's nephew no that Trump is
gonna invoke the Stafford Act okay I'm
really exaggerating but basically they
all all of these tweet all these text
messages like chained messages okay had
a similar thing my uncle works for the
government and he said just leaving a
meeting with the CDC Trump is prepared
to invoke the Stafford Act which means
that he's gonna lock down everyone get
your supplies now run and these texts
went viral like crazy okay and there
were always some how different like
someone sent out ten of them at once
slightly different okay I wonder why I
did like maybe see which one would make
it further there was one where I was
like my girlfriend sent me this I have a
source working in you know the news who
said this yeah and it's all fake like
this one worked the best right given
people's heads basically and everyone
believed it yeah and it's funny because
I did I did like a debunking of it now
we're actually talking about it when was
this like in the past week okay I woke
up in the morning I a text message from
a journalist saying like keeps on the DL
and it was like a screen grab of a tack
saying you know I was just a couple days
ago was it yeah this week has felt
interminable so uh well the Khurana
virus cases are gonna explode
Warren's Obama's Ebola czar as figures
show the virus is already spreading
faster in America than it ever did in
China and the US has the second most new
cases per day in the world Bravo we do
we do everything a little bit better
than everyone else and that includes
getting infected with a novel
coronavirus
yeah it's it's funny man because I hear
so many people saying the same lines
like the flu is
I was on the phone with somebody talking
about you know hey you think is gonna
get bad
well I was basically talking to people
about industry stuff we ad rates are
down advisor down and to make matters
worse it's really funny when people are
like Jim's trying to sensationalize to
make money it's like dude do you realize
when I talk about this I get second
nothing yeah I could make a video right
now where I talk about I don't know the
new Pokemon game you know Pokemon go
I could literally film myself walking
around in Pokemon go get like a thousand
views and make more money than if I talk
about the coronavirus anyway I digress
but there tons of people have fragmented
information and so they don't realize
what's going on they're like oh no man
like I heard that you know this then
this the flu is worse
we already got like 40,000 dead from the
flu and I was like since when what do
you mean right like since when oh I
don't know you mean since October no I
don't know and we and we started seeing
the uncontrollable growth around like
the end of February we had the first
case in January and then we didn't
actually start seeing the community
spread for like another full month and a
half or something right March third or
something yeah so I don't know I don't
know who Ron Klain is but apparently
he's saying and this is actually wrong I
mean so yeah this is this is the
relevant data that I wanted to show this
chart right here shows the peak of
China's corona virus outbreak assuming
they're telling the truth which I would
never do well you would never tell the
truth yeah no I was thinking to do
assuming China was telling the truth
okay
you would never assume there it just
sounded like you were like no I wouldn't
assume China song the truth Freudian
slip
our sorry asses and minds were like
right I must respond so now we've seen
cases skyrocket now here's here's the
important factor though we haven't been
doing testing so it's possible we're we
are below China you know because they're
basically the same thing with between US
and Italy and this number here of new US
cases could be the result of the fact
that we haven't been testing all that
well right or it could be the date on
his face is true and the u.s. out of
control and I think that's actually a
fair assessment you know why because
we're not a throwing everything down now
in China they'll like Club you over the
head and drag
to your house while you kick and scream
mmm in the US they'll be like please
don't go outside which is what they're
doing right now and then a bunch of
these kids go outside and start laughing
and like you know doing shots off each
others butts yeah like for real they're
really it's in Miami they're doing it
well they're not gonna be laughing in
like three weeks when they here's a
thing I know a bunch of we're gonna be
fine
yeah I'm sure I'm not gonna be like do
they get up and do I got the sniffles
not even not even then my grandma died I
don't know it's so weird right yeah when
my grandma died or that number that it's
affecting men twice as much yeah morning
twice as deadly to guys than it is the
girl yep like Wow and we just had that
feminist rant the other day huh well how
they say that coronavirus is ruining
feminists yeah feminism and she's like
now I know that the reports say it's
Venice it's worse for men but we're
talking about an economic problem it's
like not if I die or my I'm in the
hospital on a ventilator
like you're not a victim dude yeah get
off your high horse check us out though
LA County gives up on containing
coronavirus this from the LA Times tells
dr. to doctors to skip testing of some
patients well it was a good run they
give up I hope you guys enjoyed it it's
been a slice outside it's been a slice a
little slice of heaven we're gonna lock
the doors and we're gonna go full Mad
Max yeah we're gonna take the van
I ordered a cowcatcher I think it's
called a cow it's called the front the
front of the van yeah perfect yes Hank
antic wrought iron weighs like 800
pounds yes and it drags on the ground
sparks flying out we have to put the
armor panels on tomorrow yeah all right
it's worth it I don't think it's really
that bad but I think I'll be skating the
ramp out back well so we're lucky here
we're lucky man we're lucky yeah even if
all we had was a backyard a foot for
that ramp dude I love that thing I've
seen some videos from people in like New
York mm-hmm and those tiny apartments yo
man I can't believe I could not imagine
being stuck in New York yeah can do it
it'd be worse than prison because like
even if I'd be playing video games you
oh yeah but but what I'd run out of food
yeah that's no bueno and now they're
like don't go outside unless you need
food yeah but I guess here's the thing
right if you go outside what's cop in
and do it where are you going I'm
getting food okay all right later buddy
yeah I I have no food okay I'm going to
eat I'll wash our hands I'm walking the
dog me boy Sonny Boy I mean honestly I
think you brought this up like if you
went out in a cop was like what are you
doing and you are like buh buh nothing
here officer like man oh no oh you're
good you're good
move along side me along remember was it
Tommy Boy where they're driving and
they're drunk and then the cops and
they're like all right I got this
[Music]
so it's the kid so I was talking my
buddy and he told me that he's not
concerned because the police won't go
near anybody they're scared to get sick
you don't have mast and I'm gloves
something like 35 cops in New York you
got it right yeah oh really
yeah and so he's like you think of cops
gonna want to come up to you know and be
like come here buddy where I go yeah no
be like he's gonna he's gonna crack
though in a little bit goes go home yeah
they're gonna be like wow he's gonna
crack them I know he's gonna get under
the PA says yeah yeah or he's gonna tap
on the glass and hold up a piece of
paper says go home and then you're gonna
sign language him you know I'm hungry
I'm sorry man yeah I am I need food I
don't know sign language but well we I
have a phone that I can just be like I'm
hungry yeah probably do that just now is
the time to get a dog because that's
like a free it's like a Hall Pass I'm
walking my dog sir yes I'm walking I'm
walking my dog to get flow mode you know
it's really funny double whammy yeah
that's really funny Bill de Blasio said
so he's the mayor of New York City he
said they're contemplating a full
shutdown order and Andrew Cuomo was like
get real bail and like a quote and
saying we're not gonna do that that's
not happening we're not locking down and
the day later he was like we're locking
down down it's my decision put the blame
on me
that was actually shocking to hear him
say that so
had to man he just said the other day
like it wasn't gonna happen and then
someone gave him a dose of reality like
time to shut the doors now I'll tell you
this we got a bunch of other silly
stories but I want to mention man you
know it scares me that was what we
mentioned we were mentioning a little
earlier people are begging for the
authoritarianism yeah and what happens
when this is all over but people now
live a life where they're under hard
lockdown and are okay with it yeah I
don't know if they're okay with it I
think it's more the fear of this virus
and if the fear remains because dude
think are they gonna keep the fear
around they already they already told us
it could last two years they're saying
MIT part a story saying it's gonna be
waves of a lot of sickness but wasn't
doesn't the sickness doesn't the virus
die in the open air when it's too hot 89
I don't know yeah and what happens when
people start becoming like hypochondriac
scared of the virus and start you know
I'm sure tons of people are doing it
right now
mmm-hmm rushing to the hospital saying
I'm sick and then spreading more fear
like panicking that they're sick there's
the there's the conspiracy theory that I
don't necessarily I don't I don't
subscribe to at all I'd say but there
are people who are saying that it's all
overblown it's all hype
yeah the reason we're seeing all the
hospitalizations is because people are
panicking I keep saying that and still
be right that it's it's just people now
saying like I think I'm sick oh man I'm
sick oh I better call the hospital and
in the hospital says we've got somebody
who we think has it and then they report
in the news and it perpetuates this you
know fear cycle I don't the reason the
reason I don't buy into that is because
you have to have all of the other
countries on the planet you know like
there's there's not one agency and
control of anything like people are
testing for this they're finding it
right remember this is popping up at
nursing homes and people nursing homes
literally cannot run to the hospital
yeah well so but the reason I bring this
up is that there is a one of the fears
that I have would be politicians six
months goes by and they're looking over
the reports and like sir no new cases we
believe it's gone whoa hold on hold on
we shouldn't say that right yeah
remember that Orval episode we're just
watching which one the one where Kelly's
the the like Jesus oh yeah so there's
there's in the show the Orval there is
they go to this planet that fades out of
existence when it comes back at seven
hundred years in the future for that
plan
right and so Kelly the woman is seen and
then and then when the planet faces back
they're worshiping while she heals some
girl like balls hits her head and she
uses like the the laser thing fix this
child's head and so it's like Star Trek
for those I don't know and then yeah 700
years go by and then they go back in and
it's like they're worshiping her she's
like the God yeah and so what happens is
they go and meet the Pope basically in
this medieval world and she explains
that simply a tool shows him how to use
it he's like wow we believed all
everything's so wrong mhm and then when
they leave he walks up to like the Bible
and he's like the people must be told
the truth but then this Cardinal guy is
like are you sure that's wise we'll lose
our power they fear us yeah as long as
they fear Kelly and he goes I guess
we'll see something I goes okay and he
pulls out a knife and stabs in the back
you know that's what it was a good
episode it was but I'm worried you're
gonna you're gonna have people who are
gonna be like there's gonna be one dude
I'm not saying there will be but I
wouldn't be surprised and this is the
point when I'm scared it could be one
guy who's sitting there thinking like
we're getting all the funding we want
we're getting to implement whatever
policies we want no one is standing in
our way and he looks that report where
it says like we've done it we've beat
the virus and then he crumples it up
criminals it throws in the trash and
says what's the next plan to fight the
virus we need to enact these policies
yeah that's what's worrying yeah that is
a frightening thanks for checking out
this segment from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show every Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. sometimes an
hour or two and we do have a full live
recorded version of the show that
includes a lot of comments and smaller
segments you probably don't see if you
want to check that out you can watch
live at 8 p.m. Monday through Friday or
become a member of this channel and for
five bucks a month you get full access
to all of the recorded podcasts every
day after the show we make them
available in the community section of
this YouTube channel so don't forget to
subscribe and stick around for more
segments and more shows Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all in the next show
you